former conservative mp dominic grieve is
with us now hello to you thanks for
joining us on the programme um your
thoughts reactions first of all
the decision of the two senior ministers
to resign
is a massive indictment of boris
johnson's
lack of moral scruples and his behavior
and his capacity for lying
and i have to say i'm listening to
nadeem whom i know
i think he will
regret having taken on this job because
his view of the prime minister
is seriously flawed this is a prime
minister who's actually delivering
almost nothing what this prime minister
is delivering is chaos and the chaos
he's delivering is underpinned by his
charlatanism and his serial lying on
which he has been very clearly caught
out
in the incident involving mr pinscher
and it's small wonder therefore that
trust in him in the prime minister is
completely collapsing i know that the
solicitor general has resigned as well
and i'm not surprised
still there though isn't he he's he's
the great survivor of this prime
minister
he is a great survivor i have no doubt
about that at all but equally it's right
to say that he's doing colossal damage
and and he's doing damage to the country
that really troubles me he's also
damaging the conservative party uh if he
continues in office the conservative
party will be destroyed by him and come
the next election it will suffer the
consequences of keeping a scoundrel in
office
and so each and every one of them is
going to be tainted
by their failure to take action to get
rid of somebody who is manifestly
unsuitable to hold office
snap election might not save him
i doubt very much it will save him i
would have thought it was a snap general
election uh and he decided to call one
he is going to
take the conservative party to its doom
um i'm never going to vote conservative
again as long as he is uh prime minister
and i think that's quite a widespread
point of view which i share with my
neighbors who many of whom are
conservative voters as well
just before i let you go a lot of mps
and certainly cabinet ministers and even
the prime minister very scared of the
1922
committee i wish i had some music there
to go
why are they so scared about it
because the 1922 committee ultimately
has the power to unseat him it can
change its own rules to hold another
vote of confidence
or vote of no confidence in the prime
minister
and i would have thought that the
accumulating problems the prime minister
has means that he is very close to
forfeiting
support from a majority of his back of
his members of parliament
any ordinary prime minister
faced with this catalogue of failure and
collapse
and of his own misbehavior would have
been long gone
this prime minister by nature and
temperament is not going to go
so
as i've said on the previous occasion
his fingers have to be priced off the
window nature i'm afraid and that is
going to be the task of conservative
back bench mps and they've got to get on
with it because if they don't the
conservative party is finished